Il y a de plus en plus de gens qui
suppriment leur compte facebook
mais où vont tous ces gens ?
Twitter
Si il y a plus en plus de jeunes sur Twitter aujourd'hui c'est pour une raison simple
c'est parce que c'est le réseau
social où les parents ne sont pas
encore dessus
- T'as vu, j'ai un "facebook"
même nom
c'est bien papa, c'est bien...
Tu fais quoi là ?
- Euh... non rien !
- Mais si t'es sur ton téléphone...
Euh... je...
Regarde ! Mamie t'as envoyé un "poke" !
Ah oui ! Elle a peut-être besoin qu'on lui change sa couche...
T'as vu, ton papa il est un peu à la mode !
Alors pour les gens qui vivent dans
une grotte
elle-même à l'intérieur d'une grotte, Twitter, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est un service qui permet de poster depuis son
ordinateur ou son téléphone des
messages de 140 caractères
appelé aussi "tweets"
les autres utilisateurs peuvent s'abonner à vos
tweets
ils deviennent donc
des "followers" et vous pouvez même suivre des célébrités comme Gad
Elmaleh, Booba,
ou Cyprien.
Petite difficulté supplémentaire : le "hashtag"
dans un tweet on peut mettre un mot
précédé d'un dièse pour indiqué le thème
alors bien sûr il ne faut pas il
utilisé les hashtags dans la vraie vie
Tu sais j'ai passé une très bonne soirée en ta compagnie
Peut-être qu'après on peut aller boire un verre chez moi... #sexe #fellation
Non mais reviens ! Reviens ! #sodomie ?
Et comme je suis un peu un vieux de Twitter puisque j'ai créé mon compte
en juin 2007...
Je vais vous mettre
sur le droit chemin
cinq tweets à éviter
numéro 1
le tweet
à une célébrité
- Justin Bieber je te kiff trop réponds
stp
je pense que ça peut lui faire plaisir un
message comme ça
ça doit le toucher au fond de son coeur, puisqu'il est sensible...
Il s'en bat
les couilles !
Donc à moins que vous aimiez parler tout seul
- à midi j'ai mangé des lasagnes, j'en ai même repris
ce genre de tweet
ne sert à rien !
Numéro 2 : le tweet mensonge
Soirée de ouf au social club avec... tous mes amis...
numéro 3 : retweeter à TOUS ses followers un tweet
qui parle de soi.
Moi quand je vois quelqu'un
qui retweet un tweet qui parle de lui, moi...
...je vois ça !
Sympa ton t-shirt !
IL A DIT QUE MON T-SHIRT ÉTAIT SYMPA !
Non mais t'es con ?
IL A DIT QUE J'ÉTAIS CON !
4 : les tweets "bonjour tout le monde" et "bonne nuit à tous"
à quel moment
de l'histoire de l'humanité
ce genre de tweet
à intéressé quelqu'un ?
Bon c'est quand que tu vas te coucher ? Il est 4h du mat'...
Non ! Je peux pas ! Je peux pas tant que...
*toniiiight...*
*we are yooooung*
numéro 5
des tweets à éviter
les tweets à vous-même !
Pourquoi ça n'arrive qu'à moi ?
J'aurais pas dû me
lever ce matin
un tweet que vous seul pouvez
comprendre...
POURQUOI ?
autant l'écrire sur un bout de papier,
le ranger dans une pochette que vous
jetterez à la poubelle
c'est le même résultat
bien sûr si vous préférez les
photos, il y a toujours le service
Instagram qui permet de publier des
photos avec des filtres sympa
et qui sait
peut-être que votre photo va devenir
populaire
On sait pas !
NON JE DÉCONNE !
Quand on regarde les photos populaires sur Instagram
il y a :
Des filles bonnes, des filles bonnes, des filles bonnes, des filles bonnes
des filles bonnes, un animal mignon, et des filles bonnes !
Et dire qu'il y en a qui essayent d'être populaire en postant une photo
de coucher de soleil...
Ils sont naïfs ! Il faut montrer ses nichons !
maintenant il ne vous reste plus qu'une
seule chose à faire : Me suivre sur
twitter, et sur Instagram, compris ?